je me permets de vous poser une question
que particulier en problèmes de l'île de
france
les zones urbaines progresse
considérablement est ce que les
agriculteurs semblent ne se préoccupent
justement de ce problème et sont
inquiètes les agriculteurs s'en
préoccupent les pouvoirs publics
également il ya actuellement des
concertations qui sont en cours pour
permettre bien sûr la progression
humaine qui est inéluctable tout en
sauvegardant ce qui est essentiel à la
fois aux agriculteurs mais aussi à
l'ensemble des zones urbaines c'est à
dire le maintien d'une agriculture qui
seule permet de maintenir les zones
rurales et donc les équilibres de ces
régions
noélie doute c'est la plus belle à ses
notes cette année l' importante
participation internationale et
notamment des pays de la communauté est
ce que ceci vous dire que c'est une
concrétisation des efforts des
différents ministres de l'agriculture
que vous étiez n'y apprend comment ça
veut dire surtout que les éleveurs ont
fait un effort considérable à la fois
pour la qualité mais également pour
l'organisation et fort qui d'ailleurs se
poursuit et qui leur permettra sans
aucun doute d'en bénéficier
grâce à l'exportation qui
honteux
voir en fonction de l'effort vise
l'agriculteur fait que accompagné ou
faciliter les choses le fond du problème
c'est que les éleveurs français sont
devenus certainement actuellement les
meilleurs du monde et toutes les races
qu'une voyant ici aujourd'hui en
témoigne amplement je crois que personne
ne peut le contester